Alexa navalny on trial again in a case
which could add another 30 years to his
term this time on extremism charges the
trial happening not in Moscow but inside
the prison Colony four hours to the east
where navalny has spent long spells in
solitary confinement journalists kept in
a separate room
[Music]
the audio connection abysmal as navalny
himself spoke before the judge decided
to close the trial altogether
[Music]
foreign
T figure after almost two and a half
years behind bars with how he was
rallying the crowds in protest after
protest defiant always in the face of
multiple arrests
courageous enough to return to Russia
even after he was poisoned
knowing he would face immediate arrest
the Kremlin always denying any
involvement in his poisoning his father
Anatoly drawn and anxious watching from
a separate room both parents were there
they have endured so much
they have no shame no conscience no
honor his father said as he left
for all the secrecy around the trial
though navalny is still managed via
social media to call for what he says
will be an election campaign against the
war and against Putin wide-scale
clandestine activism to try and turn the
public mood the idea is to try to
persuade as many people as possible
using call centers Messengers social
networks to
so just for them just to start to see
the truth
people living near the jail now housing
Russia's most famous prisoner did not
much care about his trial or about him
and this will be the problem he faces if
navalny could not turn the country in
the time when he was free he stands an
even smaller chance from behind bars
which is exactly why the Kremlin keeps
him there magnney Sky News